[Music]
right after doing some research we found
some of the really disturbing things
like and rumors and a lot of evidence
that led to it and we just really wanted
to share it because that's like not okay
and with all the recent events out here
lately like we just think it really
needs to be told now back to dan
schneider this is his twitter at danrap
there's a tweet that he said toes
similar to fingers but not nearly as
good who agrees there's so many he runs
like the victorious account the sam and
cat account like icarly county always at
one point he was tweeting he tweeted a
picture of like jeanette mccurdy's toes
who was a star on icarly he's like guess
whose toes they are they're so beautiful
and soft and delicate i just want to
like cuddle with them or something weird
along those lines
that's that's not behave like
this what i'm saying like before
everyone goes yeah but there's just do
some that imagine if your kid comes back
and goes hey you know today when i was
at school the teacher was rubbing my
feet you would go and beat the ever
living [ __ ] out of the teacher like i'm
not saying it's illegal but it's
something where a parent would go dude
don't [ __ ] touch my kid yeah like we
can't because lee says in the chat he
paid somebody a hundred dollars at least
in reddit they said as a background
actor a hundred dollars
yeah i was 12 years old and what go
ahead tell the story
well basically um i saw this thing on
rabbit read it and she was an extra on
the amanda show and she talked about how
dan paid her 100 dollars to see if her
feet were ticklish and he took her in
the office alone and complimented her
feet and like tickled them
and he said from there he just started
like rubbing them and complimenting them
and she was like 12 years old now this
one here is ariana grande like crawling
on the table and licking her lips like
that is come on yeah that took that took
115 takes yeah okay so tell me that
somewhere during take 30 somebody is
nobody on the set was like uh
hey i got a question are we really gonna
is this gonna end up in the final cut
with her licking her lips on the light
which is very clearly like a school
library table
like the whole thing is just
just reeks of like pedophilia like like
to look at an image like that it's like
what do you do like even the setting of
it is school and like
this she's wearing like a [ __ ]
letterman jacket like
you got you know what i mean there's a
certain level of detail that went into
that no no mike i want you to read the
second one uh this is when she was
underrated she was 15. now all right
who wants to see jeanette mccurdy's toes
i've got plenty of pics to go around if
you tune into the new icarly episode
eyeballs yes this friday on nick um
there's no nothing to do with balls in
the episode there was somebody that used
to write blind items for you know
hollywood people and a lot of people
speculated that it was robert downey jr
but he said we don't know for a fact if
it was we actually later on said well we
don't know right but it's very
speculative that's why we put that so
they wrote about uh dan schneider he's a
monster the worst predator alive and if
you wonder why nobody will confront or
charge him he's in charge of multiple
hit shows for nickelodeon harvey
weinstein nickelodeon rakes in oceans of
money tens of millions of dollars
multiplied by many years in many shows
not to mention his merchandising
royalties so viacom nick warned him to
cool it then pay for his damn lawyers uh
what about the parents no tweener parent
who shoved their kid into the limelight
from birth is going to cross him either
and risk career suicide and a loss of
revenue and residuals and future career
no matter how
bad it [ __ ] up the kids especially if
there's multiple kid actors in the
family and the kid agents are complicit
too just ask the spears family which you
guys mentioned earlier a lot of
settlements get paid out uh from viacom
account i worked in the entertainment
industry for uh for almost 10 years and
and
uh
schneider came up quite a few times with
some of the people that i worked with
and this guy is just an absolute scumbag
it goes far beyond feet he would have uh
he would have pool parties and invite
all the kids over
and be like oh we'll just take care of
the kids no adults need to come over
so he was having he was having pool
parties with these kids uh that are on
the shows uh without any kind of adult
supervision going on
wow that's [ __ ] weird dude now
we're cooking with gas this is getting
[ __ ] weirder with this guy uh also a
friend one of my friends that used to
work on a couple of shows they did i
mean this goes back to the mid early 90s
uh this is this is back from from like
the all uh all i believe the show is
called like all that and keenan and kell
and all that um it was shows from from
way back then yeah that was [ __ ]
shows we watched yeah when we were
children
yeah and he would um and he would spend
extremely large amounts of time uh along
with the kids in their in their dressing
rooms
and uh without without any other without
any adult supervision in there either uh
he would get mad if you went and if they
at the talent uh wrangler the person who
would usually handle all the talent make
sure they were on set when they needed
to be if they were going and they and
whichever actor actress needed to be on
on set if they went to go get him and he
was in the middle of talking to him he
would just berate the uh the poor pa
that was just trying to do their job for
interrupting them
he was just uh he's just a sick dude and
people have known about this in the
industry for a long time this isn't
anything that's new to to people within
within there and it's not anything new
to nickelodeon either i don't know why
nickelodeon continues to put up with
this guy
you